fourth of july weekend travel may have
revived the covent threat in the u.s
especially for unvaccinated people who
are most at risk from the more
contagious delta variant about 8 million
passengers went through u.s airports
between july 1st
and the 4th nearly tripled the number
from last year errol barnett is at
washington's reagan national airport
errol i i traveled this weekend it was a
mess
yes jamie so you were among the hundreds
of thousands of people who traveled
through airports like this one
at dca this holiday weekend and all of
this
travel is happening right after the
delta variant
have been doubling every two weeks that
had also
popped up in all 50 states and that
preceded this recent holiday scramble
there was a real sense of revelry on the
4th of july as an estimated 48 million
people
left their homes to celebrate it's good
to be free again without the mask
at least outside but the growing threat
is the delta variant of covert 19.
it's 40 to 60 percent more transmissible
with indications it may cause more
serious disease
it now makes up more than a quarter of
all cases nationwide
all this travel this weekend mixes
people up
the delta virus is traveling also so
it will be introduced everywhere dr
william schaffner is an infectious
disease expert at vanderbilt
we may indeed see cases start to go up
again
along with hospitalizations and then
down the road
once again deaths yesterday california
announced the delta variant is now the
dominant strain in the state
making it at least the fifth state where
the new strain has taken over
in places like arkansas wyoming and
nevada
where full vaccination rates are below
50 percent
cases are once again spiking nevada
governor steve sisilak is trying to buck
that trend
with his state leading the nation in new
covert cases
5 million dollars in cash and prizes
for nearly 2 000 eligible nevada
residents who have been vaccinated
this gamble could help as long as people
get their second dose
in texas for example more than a million
people skip their second vaccine
appointment
which is about nine percent of those
eligible
and that's why we have to underscore
this pandemic is not over that low
vaccination rate or people who only have
one dose
really does have health officials
concerned consider that in a recent uk
study it found that the efficacy rate of
the fisa vaccine drops
to 33 for those who only have one dose
jumps up to 88 percent for those who
have two doses
and for the vulnerable that really could
be the different scale between life and
death
yeah keep saying the numbers errol it
makes sense to complete the process once
you start if you're supposed to get
two please get two thank you very much
errol bournette